how would you describe your style on the
chessboard
yeah i'm clearly an intuitive player
but it's actually difficult to
label me into one category because
sometimes i like playing you know
aggressive choice but sometimes i like
playing technical choice
um i consider myself to be like
universal player and play like in any
type of position
quite quite well um
yeah i mean it's probably
i mean it depends on the mood i guess
because sometimes i just also don't
understand my uh
my way of thinking like uh yeah
sometimes we just you know wake up and
decide to play like torture opponent and
play for six hours you know and squeeze
like very very minimal edge but the
other day you just want to crash and win
miniature so yeah probably i'm lucky
being lucky is very important
and every aspect in life basically um
yeah but i'm also kind of starboard and
that's okay one can call it black but
also being stubborn makes you
open like playing
words i guess in general and making
mistakes so um yeah that might be my
greatest strength
i don't i don't think i have
particularly you know one very very weak
spot
like i'm kind of you know
how to say um or a round player and
of course there are some uh strengths
and weaknesses but um i don't think they
you know like differ that much i mean
it's difficult to say because um it also
kind of depends on the mood and
yeah i said sometimes i if i want to
play something crazy then of course i
will try some sharper
opening
if not just
yeah italian is probably mine
what openings have you used in all the
games that you won against magnus over
the last few years
yeah i'd wear different openings in
champions just when i played c4 in the
first move and there was some chaotic
position
early on um
instead of anger i played e4 and there
was karo khan it was also kind of
crazy crazy position very tactical
um
yeah but smartness choice back then in
stavanger
yeah just to play a good choice and try
new things just playing and guys strong
position is like the key to development
and
yeah i'm just happy to have the chance
to play against them
and i will definitely freestyle a little
bit
also in terms of openings
yeah but we'll just see